[Musique]
france 3 c'est la chaîne des
législatives priorité aux résultats à
22h15
bfc point france 3 point fr vous le
savez c'est notre site internet pour
retrouver l les différents résultats que
nous vous donnons depuis le début de
cette soirée des invités pour commenter
avec nous fadila khattabi
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes arrivé en tête
dans la troisième circonscription de la
côte d'or pour la république en marche
face à vous antoine hoareau est toujours
avec nous pour le parti socialiste dans
son contre soir est à vos côtés pour
l'est républicain rémi delattre
bonsoir bonjour à vous en ballotage dans
la deuxième circonscription de la côte
d'or nous y reviendrons dans un instant
les résultats donc avec et un focus sur
l'yonne avec vous les liens de l'air en
commençant par la 2e circonscription de
l'yonne où on retrouve en tête jean yves
caullet le député-maire d'avalon suivi
d'andré villiers le président du conseil
départemental 3e circonscription de
l'yonne c'est michel crouzet la
candidate de la république en marche qui
arrive en tête avec 28,6 % devant le
conseiller régional du front national
julien odoul 25,6 est le plus gros score
du front national dans la région pour ce
soir et puis la première circonscription
de l'yonne auxerre est la puisaye paul
c'est le candidat là encore de la
république en marche
paulo da silva moreira qui arrive en
tête avec 33 7% des voix devant le
député sortant les républicains
guillaume larrivé avec 29% des voix
guillaume larrivé est avec nous en
direct sur france 3 guillaume larrivé
donc deuxièmes en ballottage défavorable
dans cette 1re circonscription de
l'yonne et guillaume larrivé arrivé
derrière ce candidat en marche
c'est une déception pour vous c'est la
victoire de quelqu'un qui ne vient pas
du sérail politique
ce soir je lance un appel à toutes
celles et tous ceux qui veulent un vrai
députés s'exprimant à l'assemblée
nationale comme sur le terrain d'une
voix libres et indépendantes et tout est
ouvert parce que je suis au coude à
coude avec un candidat qui a été désigné
par le maire socialiste de seurre et qui
ne serait qu'un député inutile à temps
partiel parmi des centaines d'autres
députés
marchant au pas obéissant aux nous
au parti présidentiel alors dans les
jours qui viennent je vais rassembler je
vais rassembler très largement et je
vais gagner avant de conduire pendant
cinq ans à l'assemblée nationale une
bataille pour la france et pour les
français
pardonnez-nous guillaume larrivé mais en
quoi est ce qu un député d'opposition
est plus utile et plus efficace qu'un
député qui dans la majorité va voter des
lois elle va pouvoir contribuer un
certain nombre de textes
je suis convaincu que les habitants de
la puisaye forterre de l'auxerrois de
l'aillantais comme du coup langeois
n'hérite un vrai député indépendant et
pas un godillot qui sera noyé dans la
masse parmi des centaines de députés qui
vont seulement obéir au président de la
république
ma conviction c'est que notre territoire
mérite d'être défendue par un député qui
est totalement engagée qui est à la fois
expérimenté et qui a l'énergie du
renouveau et bien ce député
c'est moi puis 2012 et ce sera moi aussi
entre 2012 et 2017 parce que je vais
gagner en rassemblant très largement
j'en suis absolument convaincu
merci guillaume larrivé pour cette
réaction en direct de l'yonne les
résultats pour la saône-et-loire
maintenant alors le refrain va être un
peu toujours le même les candidats dans
marche en tête systématiquement dans
toutes les circonscriptions première
circonscription mâcon cluny benjamin
dire qu'il s'entête 37,8 devant le maire
de mâcon jean-patrick courtois
22 15 % 2e circonscription paraît
charolles là encore le candidat la
république en marche qui est un candidat
du modem vincent chauvet en tête 31,3
devant la candidate des républicains
josiane corneloup 24% troisième
circonscription autun le creusot
le député sortant le frondeur ps
philippe baumel n'est pas qualifié pour
le deuxième tour
c'est rémy rebeyrotte le maire d'autun
candidat de la république en marche qui
est en tête avec 33% devant le candidat
des républicains
même refrain que dans les deux autres
circonscriptions 17 5% des voix
4e circonscription la bresse et tournus
c'est la candidate de la république la
république en marche catherine cabrel en
tête avec 24% des voix 2
la députée sortante cécile untermaier
qui sera au deuxième tour avec 18 % des
voix maxime thiébaut le candidat fn
n'est pas au deuxième tour sur cette
circonscription est la cinquième
circonscription chalon montceau
montchanin
le député sortant socialiste christophe
sirugue le seul ministre de bourgogne
franche comté qui était candidat sur ces
élections ne sera pas au deuxième tour
c'est raphaël gauvin candidat de la
république en marche qui est en tête
avec 30% des voix devant le maire les
républicains de chalon gilles platret 19
6% des voix résultats complets pour la
saône-et-loire et justement nous allons
en saône et loire où nous attend le
maire de mâcon jean-patrick courtois
gilles platret pas la trêve nous attend
cette fois pas très content et assez
bien gilles platret c'est pas ma
concession pour la 5e circonscription de
la saône et loire avec vous gilles
platret vous arrivez donc en deuxième
position derrière le candidat de la
république en marche et le député
sortant christophe sirugue et éliminée
dès le premier tour
est-ce que je peux être à nous entend
visiblement petits soucis
oui si avec vous vous entendez avec vous
m'entendez on vous entend donc la
cinquième circonscription de saône et
loire je vous disais oui vous avez lé en
deuxième position et où le député
sortant christophe sirugue et est
éliminée c'est un petit peu comme comme
aux municipales et en 2014
écoutez les choses sont un peu
différentes parce que là on à entrer
dans le jeu un candidat sorti de nulle
part qui vient auréolé d'une parole
présidentielle sans connaître au cas les
dossiers et qui je note quand même fait
un des scores les plus les plus
médiocres pour son mouvement dans le
département de saône et loire
donc j'ai pas à commenter la défaite de
christophe sirugue christophe sirugue
avait le mérite d'être quelqu'un qui
connaissait le terrain on avait des
différences de fond est notable et bien
évidemment on les a maintes fois exprimé
mais moi je préfère toujours quelqu'un
qui connaît les dossiers même s'il perd
mon avis à quelqu'un qu'il ne connaît
absolument pas comme monsieur gauvin mon
adversaire du deuxième tour
ce qui est particulier gilles platret
ccra fall gauvin souvent dit qu'il avait
quand même une sensibilité de droite pas
tout le temps mais sur un certain nombre
de dossiers
alors ça va se jouer sur coise deuxième
tour de l'élection présidentielle et
puis de l'est sont un peu pardon
législatives
ça va se jouer sur quoi sur cette
circonscription mois on vous montre
était beaucoup on commence à fatiguer
d'un trophée ba écoute et on se reverra
peut-être plus tard pour ça mais prenons
les choses dans l'ordre d'abord la
législative et cette législative elle va
se jouer sur des dossiers qui sont des
dossiers de terrain moi j'attends que
monsieur gauvin qui avait refusé le
débat que j'avais proposée avant le
premier tour l'acceptent maintenant
parce qu'il ne pourra pas circuler très
longtemps face à ses responsabilités
il ya des dossiers forts sur cet écran
cription des dossiers la sécurité des
dossiers les à l'emploi des dossiers
liés à la santé et nous allons devoir en
de battre donc je relance ce soir
l'appel
je veux que monsieur gauvin est un peu
de courage et acceptent le débat que je
lui propose sans attendre parle endredi
mais dès le début de semaine parce qu'il
va falloir s'expliquer d'un homme c'est
bien beau d'arriver avec une étiquette
en disant j'ai dejé de vagues parenté
dans le coin ça c'est très bien sauf
qu'il a montrées pendant cette campagne
qu'il ne connaissait aucun des dossiers
et moi je lui demande de venir en parler
devant les électeurs parce que
l'illusion d'une étiquette politique
c'est bien mais la réalité c'est que
demain le député devrait sans fin sans
parler des problèmes des gens des
problèmes du territoire et pour ça il va
falloir qu'ils les connaissent un peu
donc ils viennent en parler avec moi et
puis on verra bien au bout du compte
dimanche prochain qui les électeurs
auront choisi gilles platret donc la
campagne pour le deuxième tour est
lancée en saône-et-loire et donc les
plats très con dix candidats pour 2022
ciel sociale
ce soir sur france 3 résultat pour la
côte d'or nous n'avions pas encore celui
de la première circonscription de
côte-d'or où didier martin sera face à
françois xavier dugourd voilà pour la
première on les reprend toute la
côte-d'or peut-être ça c'est le nouveau
de nouveaux résultats que nous n'avions
pas encore voilà donc en commençant par
la deuxième on a entendu françois ii
c'est tout à leur deuxième dijon auxonne
françois deseille candidats à la
république en marche en tête 32 5 devant
rémy de l'ap député sortant de la public
inquiets sur notre plateau va en parler
ensuite 3e circonscription dijon chenôve
fadila khattabi candidats de république
en marche en tête 32% elle est sur notre
plateau on va en parler tout à l'heure
devant le candidat front national c'est
à une des circonscriptions de front
national est au 2e tour jean-françois
bateliers 4e circonscription montbard
châtillon yolaine de coursan des
candidates la république en marge 25,8
devant
charles barrière le candidat investi par
l'udps et y ait l'air 17,8 la cinquième
bonne le vignoble didier paris ce
candidat la république en marche 37,15
devant le candidat de droite hubert
poullot 24,8 et vous le disiez première
circonscription c'est essentiellement
dijon didier martin candidat de la
république en marche en tête 36% devant
le candidat alors dvd françois xavier
dugourd 12,9
il n'avait pas l'investiture et il est
devant la candidate investie anarchie
qui est à l aller quoi 800 voix de
retard sur lui gros écart didier martin
en tête et il est en direct avec nous
sur france 3 ce soir didier martin pour
la république en marche c'est vrai que
c'est une campagne qui a été compliqué
cette première circonscription de la
côte-d'or j'imagine que pour vous c'est
1 1 une victoire en tout cas une bonne
nouvelle est un soulagement didier
martin oui bonsoir c'est effectivement
une satisfaction pour moi mais surtout
pour tous tout les marcheuses et tous
les marcheurs qui m'ont accompagné
pendant tous ces mois
le résultat est au delà de nos
espérances nous faisons plus que le
score du candidat macron au premier tour
de l'élection présidentielle c'est un
encouragement qui nous est donnée par
les électeurs mais rien n'est gagné
parce qu'il ya beaucoup d'abstentions et
donc nous devons dès demain retourner
sur le terrain pour convaincre pour
conforter ce bon résultat et pour
l'amplifier pour la victoire de dimanche
prochain
didier martin c'est peu dire que
l'ambiance a été tendue sur
l'agglomération dijonnaise entre les
candidats dans marché des candidats
socialistes il ya eu des affaires sur
cette circonscription
vous avez été mis en cause sur un
certain nombre de dossiers pour autant
le maire de dijon a appelé à soutenir
les candidats de la république en marche
au deuxième tour alors tout est oublié
tout est cicatrisée tout va mieux valait
à partir de ce soir
moi j'en suis convaincu je ne
connaissais pas la position du maire de
dijon je le remercie et je m'en
satisfais cette campagne aujourd'hui est
celle du rassemblement rassemblement
pour une majorité présidentielle et tous
ceux qui se sont reconnus dans la
démarche du président macron doivent
faire élire un député utile pour une
majorité agissante et solide à
l'assemblée nationale
merci lily martin en direct de dijon
pour cette réaction la côte de ruck de
représentants de ce département avec
nous fadila khattabi et rémi delattre
pour les circonscriptions de la
côte-d'or lilian et de la troisième à
vis de la vous êtes le député sortant
d'une circonscription qui a toujours été
à droite depuis son découpage comment
vous vivez ce soir le fait que françois
deseille quand des draps public en
marché du modèle soit devant vous au
premier tour 7 et les observe déjà que
différence entre le score de monsieur de
seuils de candidats modem et moi même
est relativement faible de 1000 voix et
je déplore par contre qu'il y ait une si
faible participation 49 % et je crois
que c'est une expression justement d'un
vraiment d'un malaise démocratique est
aujourd'hui un trouble profond de nos
électeurs et nous aurons besoin
effectivement demain de mobiliser ces
gens qui se sont abstenus d'abord en
leur apportant des réponses aux
problématiques qui se posent et rémy
donne at il est justement ce député de
territoire dont ont besoin d les
citoyens de la 2e circonscription un
territoire à la fois rural est à la fois
urbain un député qui fera partie de
l'opposition on imagine opposition c'est
clair une opposé une opposition donc
dans le cadre des républicains d'un
groupe républicain on peut pas imaginer
une assemblée monochrome
on peut pas imaginer que rothen comme ça
un blanc-seing un chèque en blanc au
président mothron avec une majorité qui
soit écrasante il ya quatre mille 600
voix du front national sur votre
circonscription sont dans les yeux que
ce soir
vous en tenez compte vous allez en tenir
compte dans cet entre-deux-tours mois la
difficulté pour mme aujourd'hui c'est de
récupérer effectivement les lecteurs sur
deux qui s'est abstenu et j'ai compris
dans la campagne que nous avons conduite
que ces personnes nous lance une alerte
en disant au fond ben on ne s'y retrouve
pas dans l'eau dans le débat actuel et
je comprends pas c'est retrouve pas j'ai
pas pu avoir de débat avec le président
du modem puisque en fait d'abord j'ai
très peu vu sur le terrain et quand on a
nous évoquer des sujets de fond et en
l'occurrence eux quand on lui demande
mais puisque vous allez augmenter la
fiscalité vous allez augmenter d'environ
7% la csg comment est ce que vous vous
réagissez bon on n'a pas pu avoir de
réponse
cette fracture qui est de plus en plus
forte entre les territoires ruraux et
les territoires urbains quelle réponse
on ne donne il n'a pas été à même de
nous des réponses et nous avons des on a
quelqu'un de la république en marche
alors pas question de rêver de la tenait
d'abord pour réagir à cette assez de
soirée on disait tout à l'heure avant de
souffler sur ce plateau où vous êtes une
ancienne vice-présidente socialiste du
conseil régional fadila khattabi quand
françois patriat était le président
c'est quoi pour vous ce soir c'est une
revanche c'est autre chose
non mais je suis écouté heureuse bien
sûr des résultats et je voudrais tout de
suite remercier tous les électeurs et
les électrices dont les suffrages se
sont portés sur ma candidature avant
tout alors évidemment je m'attendais
personnellement une triangulaire or il
n'en est rien donc je veux dire parce
que la participation extrêmement faible
la participation est bien sûr on te
passerai se réjouir de cela
effectivement une participation très
faible 49% effectivement donc malgré
tout pour le second tour il va falloir
faire campagne à nouveau essayer de
convaincre de la nécessité déjà de voter
et de la nécessité et contrairement à ce
que dit monsieur le député de donner une
majorité à notre président pour faire en
sorte de sortir la france de ce marasme
la france qui a été pendant très
longtemps prise en otage entre la droite
et la gauche et on a avant tout servir
on a pris des positions partisanes
plutôt que de servir la france de
l'autre un parti unique
la parti unique nous sommes deux papes
c'est 1 400 d'études est ce que c'est un
parti unique
nous sommes en tous les cas oui unique
dans le sens on nous serons tous
derrière nous serons tous derrière le
président de la république et nous
ferons en sorte de mettre en oeuvre son
programme
il n'y aura pas de fondeur ça c'est
clair un mois antoine hoareau parce que
le parti unique vous l'évoquiez tout à
l'heure quand on en parlait il ya ce
risque là avoue socialiste vous vous
dites il y aura plus qu'un seul parti a
semblé donc dans la vie politique
française
et oui et c'est les risques de cette
élection là et il va manquer de
pluralisme de pluralisme dans cette
future assemblée nationale telle qu'elle
se dessine aujourd'hui et c'est
effectivement un risque pour la
démocratie parce que dans tous les pays
où il ya un parti unique on sait ce que
ça devient derrière ils s'en sont pas là
et je connais fadila et évidemment je
sais que ces valeurs sont pas celles
mais en attendant il va falloir être
très vigilant et c'est ce que nous on
fera et on continuera de faire d'être
d'être vigilants et puis il faudra aussi
que la gauche elle se réinvente
retravaille sur sur ses valeurs et ses
fondamentaux pour réinventer et
continuer à être vigilant de toujours
inventer paris parce qu'on attendait
gaëtan gorce tout à l'heure pas certain
que vos réinvention soient les mêmes ça
va être ça la difficulté mais il va
falloir qu'on ait un débat
il va falloir que au sein du ps et plus
largement au sein de toute la gauche on
ait un débat ensemble pour voir de
quelle manière est ce qu'on peut
rassembler la gauche et continuer à
reconstruire mais la france a besoin de
gauche et la france aura toujours besoin
de gauche parce que nous défendons la
justice sociale est aujourd'hui nous
sommes les seuls à le faire et donc
qu'on a toujours besoin de la gauche en
france
dans la nièvre avec les résultats des
deux circonscriptions de la neige
puisque perrine boulet nous attend en
direct de retrouver traverse en
commençant par la deuxième
circonscription de la nièvre château
chinon clamecy à les circonscriptions
mythique depuis même si elle a été
redécoupée ya l'ombre de françois
mitterrand sur cette circonscription
c'est le candidat la république en
marche patrice perron qui arrive en tête
avec 33 8% des voix devant christian
paul député socialiste sortant c'était
sa cinquième candidature 18,29 % des
voix et puis 1ère circonscription daniel
nevers cosne sur loire
c'est la candidate de la république en
marche perrine boulet qui arrive en tête
34 7 devant et c'est une des
circonscriptions de front national s'est
qualifié pour le deuxième tour la
candidate du front national pauline
vigneron 15,8 en signalant que le
sénateur gates tango
ce qui était candidat sur cette
circonscription est éliminée alors cas
semblable à celui de fadila khattabi
ce sera un duel la république en marche
contre front national perd ngollè nous
attend en direct je vous propose de la
rejoindre tout de suite perrine goulet
donc un deuxième tour contre le front
national
c'est pas forcément la configuration
laquelle vous vous attendiez bonsoir à
tous donc si si c'est bien la
configuration dans laquelle je
m'attendais puisque vu les scores
qu'avait fait le front national au
premier tour des présidentielles il
n'est pas étonnant de les retrouver au
second tour
au deuxième tour pour les législatives
il ya une dimension symbolique dans le
fait que vous éliminez du deuxième tour
gaëtan gorce qui a été député qui était
sénateur qui est quelqu'un qui a une
histoire au parti socialiste vous le
vivez comme ça pas du tout parce que je
n'ai jamais fréquenté gaëtan gorce
avant cette campagne moi c'était un
adversaire comme un autre il n'y a pas
de il n'y a pas de plus ou de moins par
rapport à son élimination c'est un
candidat comme un autre pour moi denis
curio quai derrière vous surfez images
qu'on a tout à l'heure dans l'émission
évoqué le fait que nous verrait ce qui
s'est passé à nevers avec cette liste
municipale qui est original par rapport
à un certain nombre de parties
préfigurer la république en marche vous
pour le coup vous vous sentez rattaché à
ça ce qui s'est passé à nos verres à
nevers été un petit peu près cure triste
par rapport à ce qui s'est passé avec
emmanuel macron maintenant je suis pas
rattachée à nevers puisque je suis en
campagne pour la totalité de la première
circonscription
maintenant effectivement il ya une
dynamique sur la commune de nevers
qu'est bonne qui est celle de la
république en marche à savoir prendre
les bons éléments de tout parti et puis
les mettent ensemble pour le bien
collectif donc nous c'est ce qu'on veut
faire avec
avec cette première circonscription bien
rassembler au plus largement sur ceux de
sur cette semaine et ce deuxième tour
pour que cette circonscription se met en
marche rassemblez y compris avec les
électeurs qui ont voté pour gaëtan gorce
les électeurs du parti socialiste qui
sont nombreux 4643 voix sur la
circonscription
y compris effectivement avec les
électeurs nuggets en corse mais
également ceux de monsieur maillard et
puis tous ceux des candidats dits
modérés 1 puisque effectivement on sait
qu'on n'ira pas récupérer les électeurs
du front national mais avec tous les
autres on espère bien entendu pouvoir
rassemblés dans un but commun qui est
bien de redynamiser notre département et
puis de relancer notre circonscription
tout simplement merci perrine goulet en
direct de nevers nous le disions rit de
tout à l'heure vous voulez intervenir
quand on parlait de parti à parti unique
je voulais je voulais intervenir à la
rédaction de
khattabi pour le lui dire que l parler
de la france ce qui était d'un marasme
et elle a raison et d'ailleurs elle se
souvient probablement qu'elle a soutenue
pendant cinq ans le gouvernement enfin
monsieur hollande et le gouvernement
monsieur ayrault puis de monsieur valls
et que effectivement c'est un échec
profond que nous déplorons aujourd'hui
et je suis surpris aujourd'hui de voir
que nous désolidariser complètement du
soutien que vous avez pu apporter
pendant cinq ans à une majorité j'avais
qu'il ya malheureusement conduit la
france aux abymes
la cote quand est-ce qu'on peut dire par
rapport à ce que vous dites c'est que
l'état du pays en 2017 est largement
meilleur que l'état du pays en 2002 est
probablement pas les mêmes références
[Musique]
regarder les traits le chômage regarder
la dette de la france les cafouillages
de la croissance qui baisse la
croissance et à la paix nous regardent
et 2010 et précarité croissante ans est
venu saluer 39 ans il ya des difficultés
ventilés dans neuf ans dans la situation
d'un ministre ou alors je laisse à la
france est bien meilleur que sept
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec ce qui
vient d'être dit par monsieur hoarau ce
que je voulais dire aujourd'hui oui tout
à fait je suis avait derrière le
président de la république
moi sa démarche elle m'intéresse elle
m'a séduite
aujourd'hui ce qu'il veut lui s'est
rassemblée effectivement les français et
aujourd'hui il a un gouvernement fait
d'hommes et de femmes de gauche du
centre et de droite
donc c'est un gouvernement les
différentes sensibilités et nous allons
tous des progressistes travailler main
dans la main pour faire en sorte de
remettre la france en marche
c'est ça notre seul et unique objectif
retour en servir effectivement certaines
positions partisanes vers la nièvre à
présent la deuxième circonscription de
la nuit à vos patrice perron pour la
république en marche arrive largement en
tête avec près de 34% des voix devant
christian paul un peu plus de 18% des
voix le député sortant christian paul je
propose d'écouter et ses réactions
recueillies à quelques minutes nous
avons aujourd'hui fait mentir les
sondages
je serai avec stéphane bénédicte mon
suppléant au second tour de cette
élection législative et je vais
évidemment préparé ce second tour dans
un esprit de très large rassemblement
rassemblement des forces de gauche bien
sûr mais est bien au delà de tous les
nivernais qui veulent à l'assemblée
nationale un député utile efficace
expérimentés et combatif le renouveau de
la démocratie passe aussi par le
pluralisme des idées
ce renouveau de la démocratie
parlementaire ça peut pas être d'avoir
un parti unique
une pensée unique et l'éradication de
tous ceux qui ne pensent pas de la même
façon et donc c'est vrai à l'assemblée
nationale on voit bien il y aura une
majorité qui se dégage mais il y aura
aussi des femmes et des hommes des
parlementaires qui permettront que la
diversité des idées soient présentes et
je pense que c'est vital dans une
démocratie
christian parle sa réaction donc pour la
circonscription de saône et loire
oui un mot pour faire signaler pour
signaler que moi je me sois trompé il ya
deux députés socialistes sortants qui
ont réussi à accéder au deuxième tour de
de ces élections législatives c'est
christian paul ont bien de l'entendre et
puis c'est cécile untermaier sur la
circonscription de la bresse en
rappelant que cette circonscription
parce que vous allez dire que j'aime les
symboles
c'était celle d'arnaud montebourg avant
que ce soit celle de cécile untermaier
ce qui n'est pas rien pour la force du
symbole là encore nous avons à présent
tous nos résultats avec 15e
circonscription de la bourgogne
quels enseignements pourraient retentir
et lilian on avait parlé de vagues
on se demandait si elle est forte c'est
pas une vague c'est un tsunami très
clairement puisque tous les candidats la
république en marche sont en tête que
très clairement
même si je viens de le dire il ya deux
députés socialistes sortants qui sont en
position de se maintenir au deuxième
tour sahara est extrêmement compliqué
pour eux que pour beaucoup d'autres on a
ouvert cette soirée électorale avec
christophe sirugue il est là encore une
dimension syndical uni dansions
symbolique car il est des mots qui se
croisent il était ministre
christophe sirugue il était député
sortant il était macron compatibles il a
été battu très largement il sera pas au
deuxième tour
donc on voit bien qu'il ya à la fois une
sanction pour le quinquennat il ya une
sanction pour les sortants il ya un
front national qui à quelques exceptions
près à l'exception surtout de julien au
double qui a quand même un score très
élevé dans la troisième circonscription
de l'yonne il va falloir le surveiller
un front national qui a eu une forte ici
passion très faible et une présence très
faible dans cette deuxième tour merci
lilian la synthèse et d'autres invités
nous rejoignent dans un instant aux
côtés de jean christophe galeazzi pour
la dernière partie de cette émission
après un tour par les réseaux sociaux
avec vous à
c'est trois tweets que je vais vous dire
tout de suite la réaction de jean
philippe morel
il lui dit du grand dijon qui appellent
à voter au deuxième tour pour fadila
khattabi donc dans la troisième
circonscription de côte-d'or
ce tweet de carole bernard qui remercie
qui était donc candidate europe ecologie
les verts dans la cinquième qui
circonscription de côte-d'or et qui
remercie ses électeurs qui leur les
remercie de leur confiance voilà on va
tout de suite retrouvé jean christophe
gallais 10 pour la deuxième partie de
cette grande soirée électorale
suite de notre soirée électorale avec
notre débat autour des résultats mais
surtout des perspectives du second tour
et de cette majorité qui se dessine au
niveau national
je salue et je remercie de leur présence
ce qui sont autour de cette table et que
je vais présenter dans un instant et
puis on va aussi faire le point sur les
différents éléments qui sont en notre
possession ce soir est analysée avec 4e
série et lilian melet les grands
enseignements de ce premier tour en
région je vous donne la parole catherine
est mairie pour ce qui concerne la
franche comté
quels sont les enseignements que vous
tirez ce soir et bien tout d'abord en
franche comté sur les douze
circonscriptions nous aurons dimanche
prochain sept duels la république en
marche les républicains un duel à
signaler ici un duel de la république en
marche contre la députée socialiste
sortante barbara romagnan la frondeuse
ne totalise que 16% des suffrages
elle est en ballottage très défavorable
face à fans est charvier la candidate de
la république en marche qui totalisent
30 % 1 des voix trois duels également à
signaler entre la république en marche
et le front national c'est le cas dans
les deux circonscriptions de haute saône
c'est le cas également dans la 4e
circonscription du doubs entre sophie
montel qui est deuxième
distancé par frédéric barbier le député
socialiste sortant qui a bénéficié
également de l'investiture de la
république en marche il faut signaler
que seuls trois députés et l'air sortant
vire en tête au premier tour annie
genevard dans le haut doubs et puis dans
le jura marie christine dalloz et jean
marie sermier alors la droite est
totalement éliminés des deux
circonscriptions de haute saône alain
chrétien tout talent on sait que dans
cette circonscription il y avait deux
hommes qui se livraient un duel à
distance
alain chrétien et alain joyan des donc
leurs deux candidats se sont si j'ose
dire neutraliser et la droite est
éliminée dans cette circonscription et
alain chrétien qui vont donc ne voit pas
sa candidate qualifié pour le deuxième
tour c'était sa circonscription à 2
dit tout à l'heure sur notre antenne la
démission d'alain joyandet du poste de
secrétaire départemental des
républicains en dessous on voit donc
déjà dès ce soir il y à des règlements
de compte qui s'effectue un petit peu
partout et en franche comté
c'est à droite et on suivra ça
évidemment catherine avec beaucoup
d'attention dans les heures qui viennent
même question lilian melet en bourgogne
quels enseignements tirez-vous des
résultats de ce soir pour le second tour
et pour après synthèse rapide qu'un
circonscription 15 candidats de la
république en marche en tête après ce
premier tour dans la plupart des cas
contre les candidats de la droite dans
deux cas face à deux députés socialistes
sortants cécile untermaier en saône et
loire christian paul dans la nièvre on
l'a vu tout à l'heure dans trois cas
face à des candidats du front national
dans la première circonscription de la
nièvre on a entendu tout à l'heure
perrine boulet qui est la candidate en
arche dans la troisième circonscription
de côte-d'or
là où le ps est déchiré avec plusieurs
candidats c'est ça qui fait monter le le
candidat du front national
et puis surtout julien odoul troisième
circonscription de l'yonne c'est lé plus
gros score du front national jusque là
et il est peut-être le seul candidat du
front national ce soir en réalité qui
entre guillemets fait son score on va
sûrement parler dans l'entre-deux tours
alors je salue et je remercie de leur
présence ce qui nous ont rejoints fadila
khattabi pour la république en marche
françois rebsamen pour le parti
socialiste au nom pour la pour la mairie
de dijon l'alcool c'est fini parti
social et non mail meetic t'es pas comme
ça je viens pas au titre du parti social
je viens en tant que maire de dijon
bien sûr on a compris je vous précise et
boris obama pour la france insoumis
c'est toujours vrai ça n'a pas bougé
pour ma part oui
rémy de lattes pour les républicains ça
passe encore et françoise branger écrite
avec nous qui est avec nous depuis notre
studio de besançon pour les républicains
également je précise qu effectivement
les autres candidats ce qui n'est pas le
cas de françois rebsamen et je crois que
c'est fadila khattabi qu est la seule à
être encore présente au second tour
confirmation également évidemment voilà
alors on envoie j'ai envie de poser une
question tout de suite avec semaine
puisque vous êtes là alors maire de
dijon membres du ps aussi mes
merveilleux on sait que on sait que la
semaine a été étendu la campagne était
tendue entre candidats de la république
en marche candidat du parti socialiste
est ce que vous regrettez françois
rebsamen qui ait pas eu d'accord avant
entre vos candidats entre les gens de la
république en marche
j'avais je comprends le sens de la
question j'avais proposé trois semaines
avant un mois avant qu'il y ait une
coalition une coalition c'est ce qui
permet de définir un programme de
gouvernement et d'avancer ensemble
cette proposition a fait long feu on
reconnaît les choses emmanuel macron et
et ferrand n'ont pas voulu et donc on
s'est pas retrouvé dans une coalition
dans un programme de gouvernement et
donc on s'est retrouvé à être apporté
des candidats voulait faire quoi il
voulait casser parti socialiste vous
voulez vous faire mal ce soir je sais
pas si cette expression est juste je
crois que iso et un accord d'appareils
avec le modem et ne l'ont pas eue être
le parti socialiste sûrement des
divisions internes au parti socialiste
des prises de positions différentes des
uns et des autres est-ce que ce soir
c'est pas françois patriat qu'à gagner
face à vous oui à 74 ans on peut gagner
vous savez il est toujours c'est pour ça
pour dire le candidat du renouvellement
donc je voudrais dire les choses
clairement là il y à ce soir des
candidats en marche qui sont en tête
certains viennent de ma propre majorité
municipale
donc ça veut dire qu'on a eu quand même
un peu de sens politique de les prendre
avec nous il
ils ont je viendrai ils ont ils ont fait
leur chemin ils ont profité de ce laps
oh non pas se faire connaître parce que
finalement c'est une vague nationale
c'est une amie et en assure fait enfin
ils ont surfé sur cette vague nationale
sur ce qu'une amie
ils font tous entre eux j'ai regardé
france entière entre 28 29 30 et 34 35
36 suivant les configurations
nous faisons tous un peu près le même
score avec 50% de participation est issu
d'un président qui a fait 24 % au
premier
donc il ya un problème démocratique il
est posé ça fait longtemps que le pose
d'ailleurs ça fait longtemps que je dis
qu'on doit changer nos institutions
notamment notamment notre net mode
d'élection vous m'avez entendu dire ça
dix fois ici hollande l'a pas fait je le
félicite pas pour ça parce qu'il n'a pas
fait j'espère que françois bayrou le
fera j'espère que emmanuel macron le
fera il n'est pas concevable que on
n'est pas une assemblée nationale qui
représente la diversité politique de se
payer mais qu'on est ici j'ai dit la
même chose madame j'ai dit exactement la
même chose
là on a une chambre d'enregistrement
puisque vous le savez tous les candidats
dans marche ont signé un papier comme
quoi ils allaient voter tout ce qui
allait être proposé en ça préserve des
frondeurs nous on sait ce que ça veut
dire des frondeurs avec ça préserve des
frondeurs j'ai le sens comme des choses
relatives ça préserve des fondeurs mais
ça permet pas démocratie d'avancé dans
les grands pays démocratiques
il y à des débats il y à des échanges il
ya des programmes là on ne sait pas donc
on va on va voir on va voir et on fait
crédit on espère la réussite du
quinquennat évidemment je vous propose
de retrouver françoise branger depuis
notre studio de besançon françoise
branger bonsoir vous êtes candidate des
républicains battu ce soir dans la
première circonscription du doubs est ce
que vous allez aujourd'hui vous
rapprocher dans marché finalement du
premier ministre edouard philippe qui
finalement est issu de vos rangs bien
écoutez je vous entends très mal mais
[Musique]
les républicains vont avoir une ligne de
conduite
aujourd'hui ils sont peut-être un peu
désorienté nous avons perdu un certain
nombre de sièges je crois qu'il faut
reconstruire notre identité politique et
une autre idéologie je pense pas que
tout le monde sera au garde à vous
devant monsieur macron canadien branger
madame branger ce que vous pensez pas
que votre électorat a quand même été
déboussolé par deux choses déjà par
françois fillon les affaires et sa
mauvaise présidentiel et d'autre part le
fait qu' edouard philippe
le premier ministre emmanuel macron est
allé le chercher dans vos rangs ça des
boussoles quand même votre électorat
c'est un véritable débauche je ne cesse
pas un consensus c'est pas tout le monde
ne s'est pas mis autour de la table pour
évoquer pour concevoir un certain de
mesures qui peuvent faire avancer la
france et provoqué un certain nombre de
réformes
aujourd'hui c'est le programme de
monsieur bacrot avec quelques
participants avec des débauchages
certain premier ministre ou encore un
ministre de l'économie mais pas n'est
pas un consensus avec la droite
je crois qu'il va falloir que nous
relations un peu les cartes et que l'on
puisse se reconstruire
assez assez dingue à cette vague tout à
l'heure madame branche aimé vous parler
de reconstruction
on voit que par exemple en haute saône
la droite est en train de se déchirer ce
soir elle n'a plus de candidat au
deuxième tour est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est comme ça qu'il faut reconstruire
votre parti des républicains a coûté le
conflit en en haute saône est un conflit
personnel entre certains candidats et et
malheureusement les candidats a été
poussé par les uns et les autres
ici également sur la première
circonscription du doubs c'est la droite
qui perd parce que il y avait un
dissident
donc c'est bien parce qu'il ya une
division un moment donné que nous
n'avons plus de candidats donc c'est la
droite
malheureusement qui qui aujourd'hui en
pâtit et je trouve bien dommage
que les électeurs et on choisit certes
avec les candidates d'un nouveau
président qui peut être séduits mais
malgré tout il y aura des déconvenues de
bercy merci françoise branget en direct
de besançon pour les républicains je
vous propose de rejoindre léonie cugnaux
pour le front national
en haute-saône bonsoir
bon ça alors quelle est votre réaction
ce soir on sait que marine le pen avait
fait un très bon score en haute-saône
visiblement vous n'avez pas engrangé
complètement dans la région les
résultats de marine le pen
écoutez nous nous sommes quand même très
contents de nos résultats nous nous
qualifions pour ce second tour ce qui
démontre que les électeurs nous font
confiance et haut saônoise et les haut
saônois nous ont fait confiance dans
cette 1re circonscription de haute saône
et je n'y ai aucun doute que nous allons
continuer ces dynamiques au second tour
merci d'avoir été en direct avec nous
pour pour cette réaction lilian melet on
reprend avec nos invités en plateau très
impatient de s'exprimer je suis venu
pour participer à un débat si c'est pour
écouter des les candidats battus à
nouveau candidat je mauvais c'est pas un
problème
voilà mais chacun aimait bien sûr des
jeux de donner son avis et on va le
donner on va lui demander à brice obama
sur notre plateau candidat pour la
france soir candidat pour la france a
soumis sur la troisième circonscription
de côte-d'or
moi j'avais envie de rappeler le chiffre
alors que le pourcentage de jean luc
mélenchon 26 lors de la présidentielle
sur cette circonscription 12,6 pour vous
ce soir il se passe quoi pour la france
est soumise entre 26 et 2 0 écoutez on a
mobilisé à peu près un électeur sur deux
par rapport à la présidentielle mais ce
qui nous coûte le deuxième tour c'est
surtout la la présence de madame
bouziane qui pour une aventure
personnelle a voulu se maintenir on est
et on a regardé les chiffres nous sommes
à 1500 voix du second tour
donc elle fait 3000 voix nous environ
4200 si madame bouziane que je suis allé
voir pour discuter avec elle pour lui
poser la question de ce qui pourrait lui
déplaire dans le programme l'avenir en
commun n'a pas été en mesure de me citer
quelque chose qui pouvait lui déplaire
donc je lui ai posé la question de
pourquoi est-ce qu'elle ne soutenait pas
elle a voulu aller ont conduit d'être
dans une cantine dans une aventure et au
delà est ce que ce chiffre là on le
retrouve dans d'autres circonscriptions
pour la france inscrive zelaya pas car
abou zian donc sert que mais vous vous
couchez moi je veux bien faire de la
science fiction mais moi je veux bien
faire la science fiction pour vous on
peut passer un super moment
mais moi je suis un peu un jeu fait
racheter en doctorants j'aime bien le
concret j'aime bien là les chiffres
qu'on crée donc un moment donné les
chiffres à bouziane et les parfums s'est
soumise très bien elle était députée
socialiste mais elle était députée
d'iberville socialiste pour un 10 rounds
dans des bulles des socialistes feront
d'eux et j'entendais aussi monsieur
rebsamen moi je trouve ça assez rigolo
que monsieur rebsamen ne veulent pas
assumer cette idée de lui parce qu'il
avait l'air de gêner aux entournures
on peut lui avait suggéré que pouvaient
du parti socialiste moi dit aux jeunes
parlent de la partie sociale serait bien
mais j'aurais quand même un des
commandes issa les éléphants de ce parti
comme on dit donc défense qui est-ce qui
est ce qui est extraordinaire c'est que
moi je d'aisance plateau j'entends
parler de l'abstention c'est tout à
aucun moment on essaie de faire la
généalogie pour comprendre cette
abstention
à aucun moment on parle du gouvernement
de monsieur aulas amène hollande qui
pendant cinq ans a fait l'un vers de
scouts de tout ce qu'on parlait ensuite
on s'étonne que les gens ne veulent plus
retourner aux urnes
on parle pas des bons plans jean-pierre
dont vous êtes juste les gens qui est
extrêmement longue
depuis septembre depuis que monsieur
sarkozy est parti en campagne on nous
avons eu la primeur de la droite la
primaire de la gauche à la
présidentielle a voté les français
veulent voter sauf que kankankan quand
les personnes sont élus et qu'elles font
l'un vers de la province pendant cinq
ans les personnes se demandent pourquoi
aller voter
quand il ya autant d'affaires dans le
milieu politique les personnes se
demandent pourquoi les voter quand nos
amis du monde télé et qu'on entend
parler de monsieur macron sur son vélo
au ski etc etc on nous dit que de toute
façon et que de toute façon nous
rassemble crise et on se demande
pourquoi
il à perdre de voix non mais l'érosion
électorale de la france a promis je ne
sais pas ce que justifie ce que je vois
ce que ce que moi je constate c'est
qu'en allumant la télé ans sont
demandées presse il ya une érosion des
voix je veux dire et me disent alors moi
j'aimerais bien parce que pour l'instant
c'est que la position et de monsieur
mélenchon n'était pas très clair sacré
et j'ai une forme de maîtrise de tout
cela il se trouve que notre le candidat
jean luc mélenchon change notre ami
mélenchon le candidat jean luc mélenchon
a fait une formidable campagne tout à
fait et il a fait une campagne
présidentielle personnel comme il sait
faire et puis il sonne elle avec son
million d'électeurs personnel gonis fr
et puis il a un peu dérapé après il on a
retrouvé le mélenchon qu'on connaît et
donc les gens se sont un peu des taux
d'accord donc c'est la fois que jean luc
mélenchon c'est une l'abstention soit
pas là mais je veux raison j'aurais eu
donne d'autres raisons je parle par
rapport à l'évolution de votre coeur
donc je me permets de faire ce que nous
entendons firminy si vous pensez qu'il
n'avait aucune responsabilité sous par
rapport à l'abstention des personnes te
dire que vous étiez en noir sur nos
régions
j'ai une responsabilité par rapport aux
scores du parti socialiste et que
c'était d'accord mais sur la
participation
vous devriez aussi vous interrogez comme
tout le monde tout à fait s'émouvoir et
vraiment se poser des questions par
rapport aux taux d'abstention qui
effectivement qui atteint un niveau tout
à fait exceptionnel pour une élection
législative mais c'est quand même bien
d'abord l'échec de cinq années de
socialisme cinq années c'est votre cinq
années pendant lesquelles on savait
républicain
oui sauf que d'expliquer ensuite un
niveau d'edf qui n'a cessé d'augmenter
le taux de croissance qui est à la peine
par rapport aux autres et comme je le
disais il ya un instant un niveau de
précarité qui ne cesse de dire que c'est
ce qui nous a gênés dans un petit modèle
excuses officielles de lattes
si c'était aussi simple que ça les
candidats les républicains auraient dû
engranger davantage de voix alors que
l'on voit qu'eux ils sont à la peine
partout et qu'il perde tous des voix
dans leur circonscription
même quand ils virent en tête comme par
exemple je disais tout à l'heure
annie genevard dans le haut doubs ou
alors les deux jurassiens marie
christine dalloz jean marie sermier
alors comment vous l'expliquez sinon il
ya eu un mouvement en faveur de monsieur
macron qui est indéniable mais vous
savez j'ai observé je crois moi aussi je
prends je prends l'exemple de ma
circonscription est ce que vous pensez
que le candidat du modem aurait fait le
score qu'il a fait ce soir s'il n'avait
pas vu sa photo à côté celle de monsieur
macron c'est bien là qu'on voit qu'il ya
eu l'effet effectivement de jarny
séchage pour dire la motion c'est un
taux à côté
choses mais aujourd'hui quand vous dites
effectivement que les républicains sont
à la peine c'est vrai mais encore une
fois dans la circonscription de la 2e
circonscription de côte-d'or
j'ai fait un score qui est supérieur je
puis vous assurer que nous allons nous
mobiliser pour justement faire en sorte
que les gens aient le sentiment que j'ai
ce soir c'est que pour les gens de
droite c'est 1980 empire et pour les
socialistes et 1993 empire il faut dire
que 93 encore si ça s'arrête
ça va être une chance non ça va être une
chambre bloc national qu'on a connue en
vous n'imaginez pas ce virage était pas
parlé non mais je voudrais bien le
permet je jouerai des rameaux jmlp à
fadila khattabi
je dois dire un mois à rémi delattre
cette vision pessimiste
cette vision déclinistes que vous portez
vous avez toujours porté en dix ans la
france va mal n'a jamais été aussi mal
et c est là paf et 20% à l'élection
présidentielle 20%
c'est le score de monsieur fillon la
vérité elle est toute autre
à un moment bien renouvellement qui
apparaît à fabre une personne c'est
comme ça dans cette république qui est
tourné vers l'élection présidentielle
le problème c'est qu'une fois qu'on a
élu un président de la république est
bien derrière ça suit ça suit parce que
c'est comme ça aujourd'hui c'est un
enregistrement tout simplement c'est pas
une élection législative qui a derrière
c'est une chambre d'horizon des jalons à
voir c'est plus que mécanique je me suis
trompé je ne reçois pas très ya des
raisons n'importe quelle personne
aujourd'hui qui à l'estampillé macron
n'importe où fait entre 20 heures
[Musique]
sincèrement deux fois sur la
modification des ja du septennat on est
passé au quinquennat apports de la
cohérence à dire à partir du moment où
le président a été élu
effectivement il ya une volonté des
français et ils sont cohérents et je
fais bien sûr je comprends cette
intelligence collective de donner une
dynamique une réponse au président de la
république tout simplement mais ça donne
aussi une légitimité au candidat
démocrate
merci ce débat est terminé la soirée
électorale continue sur france 3 avec
carole gaessler et francis letellier on
vous donne rendez vous demain à 12h et
13h pour en savoir plus en région
[Musique]